welcome back to kevin hart's the kelly
clarkson show a tribute to rad dads
kevin hart is co-hosting and
co-producing today
give it up um are you happy
with your wine and your chip combo or
coffee
i'm not gonna lie to you this is good
wine but you know i feel like we can do
better if it was my oh
yes it is your show today so let's do
better okay
you want fancier chips as well yeah like
this this is good but this isn't what i
would technically have if we were at
like an event for me there's a better
chip there's a there's a better
wine yeah i feel like my suit is
deserving of a better wine
hello come on now okay
all right well can you bring that out
justin can you bring the better wine and
the better chips out you feel like
oh okay please we have a platter okay
why don't you bring this out the first
time
see thank you we're not talking about
make that out of it now we're talking
crap out of here now now we talking okay
give me a chip one that i can get some
dip and maybe i'll go to him first
[Music]
[Laughter]
now you got first because it's your
shirt thank you thank you see he knew
you get it you're starting to get it
yeah i didn't help him at all no he's
starting to get it
this is really good okay let's taste
this one is the lighting okay as well
are you good are you vibing i am but i'm
no longer feeling electric
uh i feel like now we're in the mode of
comfort yeah so give me something else
let me feel a little comfortable guys
can you hit me with something else okay
give me another little light change yeah
yeah now i'm in the house i'm feeling
warm yes yes this is so nice
yes you guys are in fact drinking duck
horn the discussion
this wine has notes of blackberry and
when it opens you'll notice espresso and
vanilla
i got the espresso vanilla too did you
taste it now after he said it i tasted
it yup
which means that next time before i
taste it tell me so i know what i'm
looking for
note yes that's a note oh no we have a
comment card we should have a box
um so wait your new book is out okay
this is awesome
um it's called marcus makes a movie so
what's your message for kids in this
book why'd you want to do this
first of all when you say that title
kelly you're supposed to punch that
title
marcus makes a movie there you go but
you don't have the drums i do
damn it marcus makes a movie
damn it yes uh mike i think my drummer
just quit and wants to work for you
by the way our timing is impeccable uh
marcus makes a movie this is a book that
i decided to write to inspire the youth
the generation
today i feel like the word no is
powerful
it's discouraging and sometimes you do
need a a little uh
a little push and understanding that no
it's not forever
it's it's a moment and this is the book
of a guy
a young kid that heard the word no and
didn't want to accept it
and he wanted to create his opportunity
which is what life is about it's about
creating and making opportunities making
the best of them and
having the ambition to drive to do it
stay with it ultimately succeed
for whatever that level of success is uh
in this case it was about
making his dream movie uh that he was
told he couldn't do because
he had no money he had no cameras and he
found a way to do it
without having those assets but by just
having the help of some friends
uh ambition and ultimately a dream and
the dream comes true but it's a nice
journey it's a good journey and i want
kids to understand that's what life is
life is a journey a journey worth living
and embracing you know why
because at the end of it we all get to
look back at our story and marcus's
story
it's amazing wow did i sum that up hit
me with it
yes that was awesome
i feel inspired first of all right now
i'm crushing
what was your experience like um i don't
know did you ever have you ever told no
about something and then you feel like
you've pushed through anyway that you
could do it somebody told you you can't
do something and you did
well kelly first and foremost let me
take the time to echo what you just said
okay because kelly that was a great it
was a great question right
i feel i was totally i was so nervous
okay we all we all were told no's at
some point in time kelly but here's the
thing
my nose ultimately became my
drive and want toward my yes right i was
told that i wasn't funny
i was told that i wasn't going to make
it i was just trying to told you that
several i was told that my movies would
never
show overseas and do business overseas
i was told the likelihood of me being a
movie star was not likely i was told
everything
that is the complete opposite of what i
now am and
here's the thing when i was told that i
didn't get angry
i didn't get mad i just used it as
personal fire for myself
because i believed in a certain thing
that i felt i had
you are marcus i am marcus marcus comes
from me it comes from my life
uh and and my story we just did it in a
way to where kids would be able to
identify with it as well
yeah the word no once again is temporary
it's not forever man
and that's the biggest thing that i want
this young generation to truly
understand
i love that dream big um do you want to
read the toss
because it's your show i can't read the
talk yeah uh
guys listen to me marcus makes a movie
is available
now wherever you buy books i repeat
marcus makes a movie is available now
wherever you buy books
hit me with it one time yeah
if that was a book you would have bought
it yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever